hey guys hope all is well with you and
welcome back to another video so way
back in the day I used to make videos
just like this one where I just talked
about a topic that I found interesting
with some gameplay in the background to
distract your brain while I talk kind of
like a short podcast with a specific
topic well today I don't really have
anything specific for you guys besides
the fact that it is the one year
anniversary of Elden ring and I can't
believe an entire year can go by as fast
as it did if you're a subscriber here on
the channel you know that this game has
absolutely consumed my life for the past
365 days from software has completely
immersed me within the lands between
which was honestly a feeling that I
never thought I'd ever feel again while
playing a video game you know I'm
getting up there in age I'm almost 28
years old I've been playing video games
my entire life and based on the age
demographic that YouTube gives me you
guys are probably feeling the same way
as I do I wasn't particularly happy with
this state of gaming up to Elden Ring's
release just disappointment after
disappointment with games that I'd hype
myself up for and they'd just turn out
to be unfinished messes most of the time
but Elden Ring released in my love for
gaming came flooding back to me like I
was a goddamn kid again I will always
have a deep respect and love for Eldon
ring because of this and anything from
software decides to release I will buy
and support without question I know
absolutely nothing about armored Core
but I will pre-order armor core 6 as
soon as I can and I will play it the
moment it releases I trust from software
to release quality finished games
because time and time again they do
exactly that which is why I trust that
they will take as long as they need to
to create an incredible DLC for Elden
ring that I still believe is on its way
soon in the coming months maybe now I
say maybe because there's been this hype
for DLC over the past few months now
mainly because people think it would be
stupid from software not to release any
kind of DLC for their most popular game
ever and you'd be right for saying that
they would make money hand over fist if
they did and from the business side of
things they absolutely should make a DLC
and they probably will they have
suggested a few times that they aren't
done with eldinring and that there's
quote much more they want to do with
Elden ring now I thought this pretty
much confirmed DLC but I've started to
think that when they said this they
sounded sort of reluctant like they had
to say something or people would have
been upset if they didn't now while I
believe they will make a DLC for
eldenring especially after the insane
success that the game has seen over the
past year I don't believe they were
prepared for this success and were never
planning on making any DLC for the game
they've said multiple times through
multiple different sources that Elden
Rings success wasn't exactly expected
and that's something we all know at this
point there have been tons of
discussions all over this website about
what the DLC is going to be and when
it's going to be released but honestly
guys I think they've already told us
where they are shifting their focus
armored Core 6. I don't know about you
guys but the trailer they showed us
during the game awards absolutely blew
me away I was expecting some sort of
announcement for it but I definitely
wasn't expecting what they showed us
everything regarding Elden ring DLC has
come off with a bit of reluctance to
confirm it because now they probably
feel obligated to make it in my opinion
they don't need to make a DLC for the
game at all now do I want a DLC of
course I do absolutely but what I'm
asking is if they need to make a DLC and
to me the answer is no they really don't
eldenring is way bigger than any one of
us could have ever imagined my first
playthrough I kept asking myself if the
game would ever end and it just kept
going and going and going it literally
felt endless at times they really didn't
need to go this hard they really didn't
but they did it is filled to the
absolute brim with content even
mowgwin's Palace in the halick tree feel
like their own DLCs in addition to the
main game not like they were just
slapped into the game to make the game
bigger but that they were fully fleshed
out DLCs that they decided you know what
let's just put it into the main game now
do I want more information on the lore
of Elden ring you bet I do the major
success of this channel is founded off
of our lore videos that we've made over
the past year but like I've said for a
few months now at this point I don't
think Eldon Ring's lore is meant to give
us any kind of answer it's meant for us
to interpret what it means and how it
all connects together the main story is
very easy to understand and I say easy
in terms of it's a very simple basis
you're a tarnished you have been brought
back to the lands between to fix the
Elden ring you go from point A to point
B to point C to get that job done at
least that's what I was thinking through
my entire first playthrough and that
does hold true in terms of the lore
throughout the entire main game but all
of the intricate little details that
make the story what it is the overall
mystery of it I don't think is ever
meant to be answered the questions we
all want answered simply doesn't need to
be answered and I have come to accept
that and you know maybe I've accepted
that because I've gone Hollow trying to
understand all these little intricacies
and details that I've tried to find the
answers to for a year now and you know
in a lot of ways I feel like I've failed
this channel in that way that I haven't
been able to find those answers even
with all of your help over the past year
feeding me information on Discord and
what you guys think in the comments of
all of these videos I've made but I've
come to accept that I do not fully
understand Elden Ring's lore and
admitting that does feel like I'm a bit
of a failure but I truly don't think we
were meant to fully understand it and
accepting that for me has made me look
back on this past year with a smile on
my face going from a point of not being
able to remember all of the similar
names of the demigods to now believing
the lands between is trapped in a Time
Paradox of interwoven time frames and
dimensions is a big difference from when
we first started and that probably means
I've looked a bit too deep instead of
just appreciating what we got one year
ago today we got an absolute Masterpiece
of a game that I'm thankful even exists
it's made me appreciate gaming even more
and while it is hard to play other games
besides Elven ring because it is so
incredibly good and it actually has made
going back to other gay games and
playing other games harder just because
of how good Eldon ring is it has still
reignited this love for gaming that I
was losing and I am very thankful for
Elden ring for doing that for me so
hopefully DLC is coming soon I really do
think it is there's a lot of evidence
that points to them releasing something
in the next few months but even if it
doesn't this last year has been an
absolute honor so thank you Eldon ring
and thank you to all of you for being
here through all the ups and the Downs
of this Channel and if you couldn't tell
this channel isn't a bit of a transition
period I've started to transition out to
other games like I've done in the past
many other times I used to have a
valorant YouTube channel with 20 000
subscribers we grew a partnered twitch
stream with rocket league in amassed
over 230 000 followers on Tick Tock and
now this past year has been completely
dedicated to Elden ring and growing this
channel to over 100 000 subscribers and
the last thing I want to do is
completely stagnate with Elden ring if
we really aren't going to get any more
content in this next little while so I
would love to have fun playing other
games and making content there for you
all to enjoy and then once we get more
content with Eldon ring we will be right
back on top of that right away so just
be on the lookout for that and thanks
for hanging with me through this
transition period And I really hope that
includes more Elden ring in the future
thank you all for watching and I'll
catch you guys in the next video
take care